commencée c'est extrêmement extrêmement
prometteurs comme approche et c'est ce
qu'on a dit aux jeunes en quelque sorte
et donc on enchante rap décomposer
immunothérapeutique des cellules
immunitaires anticancer d'autres sortes
de composer nos amis directement et
plusieurs étapes qui sont relativement
simples chimiquement
mais quand même plusieurs étapes donc la
première c'est de nous on utilise en
fait de chitosane qui est issu de la
chitine qui provient de la carapace de
crustacés donc qui doit être purifiée
donc ça devient une poudre de kazan qui
ensuite est mélangé à part qu'il n'y en
solutions acides et ensuite qui est
mélangée avec un agent gélifiant qui
également en solution donc c'était un
peu ça l'heure le mystère de la recette
c'est le bon choix de ses agences
gélifiants et leur bon ratio entre eux
et ensuite on m'a donc fait simplement
mélanger ces deux agents et lorsqu'ils
seront mélangés ils vont rester liquide
à solution à température pièce mais
ensuite ils vont ce génie fier à 37
degrés et donc c'est tout là la beauté
de la chose ce sont vraiment des gels
qu'on appelle thermosensibles qu'ils
vont au début rester liquide à
température ambiante mais qui vont
pouvoir durcir solidifier in vivo les
gros des gros défi pour ce vieux j'aime
c'est qu'il soit injectable mais qui
ensuite ils forment une matrice solide
mais poreuse pour vous servir de
réservoir justement pour ces cellules
normes avantage ce biogen là c'est que
c'est pas n'importe quel bio gel c'est à
dire que les bio gels peuvent être
toxiques pour les cellules qu'on va en
capsules hier et ce qui est fantastique
ce qu'on a démontré en fait dans nos
travaux récents c'est que non seulement
les cellules vont rester dans le gel et
vont elles vont elles vont être
heureuses là et pendant deux semaines
trois semaines des lèvres les
lymphocytes t les cellules immunitaires
qu'on vend en capsules et dans le bios
jeunes vont continuer à proliférer vont
être très heureuse et même elles vont
sortir du gel dans le monde et elles
sont capables de sortir du gel et
d'aller twenty maquis à côte ils sont le
modéliser une vie trop donc ça
fonctionne à savoir que le bio gel non
seulement permet d'encapsuler des
cellules et des composés mes cellules
restent très heureux c'est pas toxique
et les cellules peuvent même continuer à
fonctionner
et à sortir du gel